¿Y si os digo que hay un país en Europa
que está ganando dinero con la crisis energética?
Un país democrático, miembro de la OTAN
y que tiene gas y petróleo a raudales ¡Exacto!
Noruega.
El país de los salmones y el black metal.
Tras el cierre del gas ruso, son muchas las
miradas que están puestas en Noruega.
Un país que hasta ahora era la segunda fuente
de gas natural para Europa por detrás de
Rusia.
Pero la pregunta del millón de dólares es:
¿Será capaz Noruega de salvar a Europa con
su gas?
Sea como sea, lo que está claro es que Noruega
se está haciendo AÚN MÁS RICA con la guerra.
Y esto es importante porque Noruega no sólo
es importante por el petróleo.
Además, tiene un enorme peso en el mundo
de la empresa ¡Habéis oído bien!
Pese a que tienen poco más de 5 millones
de habitantes, el estado noruego tiene uno
de los fondos de inversión más grande del
mundo: El Fondo Soberano Noruego.
Buena parte de los beneficios que ganan con
los combustibles fósiles se invierten en
activos a lo largo y ancho de todo el mundo:
plantas de energía renovable, deuda, inmuebles
y acciones de las mayores empresas del planeta.
Y esto puede llegar a tener consecuencias
muy importantes para el día a día de todos
nosotros.
Incluso en ámbitos que quizás nunca sospecharíamos:
¿Qué tiene que ver Noruega con las fake
news de Facebook?
¿Qué tiene que ver Noruega con las luchas
sindicales en Amazon?
¡No me he vuelto loco!
Al final de este vídeo entenderéis por qué
todo lo que ocurre en Noruega puede llegar
a tener consecuencias en Wall Street... y
en nuestra vida diaria.
Por supuesto, no ha faltado tampoco quienes
los han acusado de egoístas como el primer
ministro polaco.
Pero en Noruega lo de que no te haces rico
regalando el dinero lo saben muy bien.
De hecho, a pesar de ser un gran país petrolero
tienen uno de los precios de la gasolina más
altos del mundo.
Así que las preguntas que hoy nos hacemos
son ¿Cómo está afectando la guerra de Ucrania
a los noruegos?
¿Qué impacto puede tener esto en la economía
mundial?
Hoy, vamos a responder a estas preguntas pero
antes, vamos
a
ver
un poco de historia.
T1 (LA EXCEPCIÓN NORUEGA)
Noruega es actualmente el mayor exportador
de salmón del mundo, exporta a más de 100
países.
Pero no solo exportan salmón.
Noruega es uno de los grandes productores
de zumo de dinosaurio y de gas.
Aunque a todos nos gusta el salmón, son los
hidrocarburos los que representan entre un
40 y un 70% de exportaciones de Noruega, y
los que han hecho de Noruega un país tan
rico.
No fue nada fácil encontrar petróleo en
Noruega.
Durante los años 60, hicieron más de 200
perforaciones hasta encontrar un yacimiento:
el yacimiento petrolero de EKOFISK ¡Y ya
sé lo que estaréis pensando muchos!
Sobre todo los que ya conozcáis VisualEconomik,
nuestro canal de economía ¿Un país descubre
petróleo?
¡Cuidado!
¡Pueden caer en la maldición de los recursos
naturales!
¡Exacto!
Tener muchos recursos naturales no implica
ser rico.
En muchos casos ocurre justo lo contrario.
Pero eso os lo explicamos con todo detalle
en un vídeo de VisualEconomik, que os dejo
en la descripción.
Sin embargo, Noruega no es ni Rusia ni Venezuela.
Es un caso muy especial.
Atentos.
(En 1972, Noruega creó la empresa estatal
de petróleo: STATOIL, que ahora se llama
EQUINOR.
En 2001 Stateoil sacó a cotizar parte de
sus acciones en las bolsas de Oslo y Nueva
York, pero el gobierno mantuvo el 81,7% de
la propiedad.
Luego en 2007 llegaría una fusión con la
división de petróleo y gas de Norsk Hydro,
el principal productor de energía hidroeléctrica
de Noruega.
Ahora mismo, el Estado Noruego es propietario
de algo más del 68% de Equinor.
Por supuesto esta empresa reparte dividendos…
Qué son cobrados mayoritariamente por el
gobierno noruego.
Claro que esa no es la única vía de ingresos
pública.
El gobierno noruego también es copropietario
de muchos de los yacimientos de gas y petróleo
del país, al tiempo que los impuestos sobre
los beneficios procedentes de la explotación
de crudo son altísimos.
En concreto el estado se puede llegar a quedar
con más del 75% de los beneficios.
Es decir, que si hablamos de petróleo en
Noruega, el mayor beneficiario siempre es
el estado.)
Y la pregunta es ¿Qué han hecho con todo
ese dinero?
Pues bien, en 1990, Noruega creó el llamado
FONDO SOBERANO NORUEGO: un fondo de inversión
estatal con el propósito de invertir los
excedentes de los ingresos del petróleo y
el gas.
Y diréis ¿por qué?
Pues porque este fondo soberano amortigua
todas las crisis ¿Baja el precio del petróleo?
No hay problema: Noruega tiene inversiones
en toda clase de activos.
Activos, que por supuesto, no tienen nada
que ver con el petróleo.
Este fondo está gestionado por una división
del banco central de Noruega.
Lo que a muchos os puede sorprender, es que
el fondo soberano de Noruega es el fondo soberano
más grande del mundo junto con el fondo principal
de China y el fondo de Abu Dhabi.
Atentos a esta gráfica.
Para que os hagáis una idea, en 2013 el fondo
representaba el equivalente al 183% y en 2022
ya representa más del 225%
Pero no solo eso, a diferencia de los programas
públicos de otros países, este fondo ha
tenido un crecimiento casi constante.
Incluso han obtenido importantes retornos
tras la pandemia del COVID y los bajos precios
del petróleo.
Y os preguntaréis ¿Pero cuánto petróleo
produce Noruega?
Pues lo cierto es que no demasiado.
(A nivel mundial, Noruega produce aproximadamente
el 2% del petróleo que se consume y el 3%
del gas.
Muy por detrás de lo que producen países
como Estados Unidos, Arabia Saudi, Rusia,
Canadá o Brasil entre otros muchos.
Para que os hagáis una idea, en 2021, Arabia
Saudita produjo en torno a 9 millones de barriles
diarios de petróleo, Estados Unidos 11 millones,
Canadá 4,7 millones y Noruega aproximadamente
1,7 millones de barriles.
Eso sí, en lo que respecta al gas, Noruega
es el tercer mayor exportador de todo el mundo
tan sólo por detrás de Rusia y de Qatar)
En cualquier caso su diferencia, su secreto
respecto a otros países se ha basado en ser
uno de los pocos países que invierte en bolsa
y diversifica sus ganancias del petróleo
y el gas.
De esta forma el gobierno está prácticamente
garantizando el futuro de los noruegos.
Y es que, fijaos, por norma general los gobiernos
son deudores netos.
Es decir, tienen deudas con el resto del mundo.
Por ejemplo, en el caso de Estados Unidos,
la deuda pública equivale a unos 93 mil dólares
por ciudadano estadounidense; en el caso de
Italia equivale a más de 50 mil; y en el
de España a más de 30 mil.
Pues bien, en Noruega la situación es completamente
diferente.
¿Sabéis cuánto pagaría cada noruego de
deuda pública?
Absolutamente nada.
Podrían pagar toda la deuda pública del
país con el dinero del Fondo Soberano y aún
les sobraría más de 180 mil dólares por
cada noruego.
Tanto los partidos de derechas como de izquierdas,
han sido conservadores con el fondo y no lo
han derrochado.
Algo difícil de imaginar en otros países
donde llegar al poder muchas veces supone
un reparto del botín para ganar votos.
La primera retirada de dinero del fondo soberano
se produjo en el 2016, cuando se gastaron
780 millones de dólares para contrarrestar
una recesión económica causada por los bajos
precios del petróleo.
De esta forma, Noruega apenas notó la crisis
del petróleo.
Es decir, para entendernos.
Que si se produce una nueva crisis del petróleo
que hiciera sufrir mucho a otros países productores,
Noruega no tendría ni que notar dicha crisis.
Pero, ¿queréis un dato que os puede hacer
explotar la cabeza?
En 2021 el gobierno noruego ingresó unos
30 mil millones de dólares gracias a la explotación
de petróleo en el país.
Pues bien, la rentabilidad media del fondo
soberano noruego, en torno a un 5,8% desde
su creación, supone que en un año típico
el estado “gana” más del doble con los
beneficios del fondo que con los propios ingresos
del petróleo.
En otras palabras, que Noruega ya es más
dependiente del Fondo que del Petróleo.
N1 (“El ‘gran ahorro’ que salva a Noruega
de la crisis petrolera”)
Pero más allá de ser muy ricos, la pregunta
es, ¿puede Noruega ser la salvación de una
Europa que se dirige al gasmagedón?
Ahora mismo lo vamos a ver.
T2 (¿NORUEGA AL RESCATE?)
Noruega ya era un socio clave de la Unión
Europea antes de la guerra de Ucrania.
Exportaba el 20% de la demanda de gas natural
en Europa.
Hasta el año pasado, Bruselas pedía a Oslo
que dejara de perforar en el Ártico por razones
ecológicas.
Ahora, sin embargo, Bruselas está pidiendo
a Oslo que saque petróleo y gas de donde
puedan.
El objetivo es reemplazar el gas ruso con
más gas Noruego y de otros países.
De momento, Noruega ya se ha comprometido
a aumentar las exportaciones a Europa para
hacer frente a la crisis energética
N2 (Noruega elevará un 6,8% su producción
de hidrocarburos para 2023.
EuropaPress)
Un incremento que se suma al que ya han tenido
durante el 2022.
Durante este año Noruega producirá un 8%
más de gas natural que en 2021.
En total el incremento en la producción de
petróleo y de gas será de casi un 15% en
2021 y de un 6,8% en 2023.
Casi un 23% en apenas dos años.
Así que si hablamos nuevamente como conspiranoicos:
¿Podéis adivinar cuál es el país europeo
que más se ha beneficiado de las sanciones
al gas ruso y del sabotaje al Nord Stream
I?
¡Exacto!
Noruega.
Casualmente un nuevo gasoducto noruego se
ha puesto en funcionamiento el 1 de octubre.
El gasoducto se llama “Baltic” y ya ha
empezado a conducir gas desde Noruega a Polonia
pasando por Dinamarca.
El gasoducto baltic, transportará 10 BCMs
de gas al año hacia Polonia.
Si hasta ahora Noruega satisfacía el 20%
de la demanda europea de gas, este año se
calcula que ya estaría cubriendo un 25%.
Y se espera que para el año que viene el
porcentaje sea aún mayor.
Es más, desde el propio gobierno de Noruega
dicen lo siguiente.
C1 ("Ellos [Europa] necesitarán gas de otras
fuentes además de Rusia.
Creo que es difícil ver muchos lugares desde
donde sea más natural seguir importando gas
en un contexto europeo que el de Noruega".)
C2 ("Para nosotros, es importante que sepan
y les demostremos que Noruega es un socio
energético fiable, digno de confianza y a
largo plazo para Europa")
(Andreas Bjelland Eriksen, Secretario de Estado
del Ministerio de Petróleo y Energía de
Noruega.)
Y EQUINOR ya ha dicho que va a subir la producción
¡Pero esperad un momento!
Si bien Noruega está dando un pequeño respiro
a Europa con su gasmagedón, no será la solución
definitiva de momento.
A veces querer no es poder.
En Noruega se están frotando las manos con
todos los ingresos extras y quieren vender
más gas a una Europa necesitada ¿El problema?
Que Noruega no puede duplicar su producción
de gas de un día para otro ¡No sólo eso!
Antes de la guerra, había quien incluso decía
que había que dejar de extraer hidrocarburos
tan pronto como en 2035.
Vale, este era el caso de los verdes, pero
ojo, porque, el propio Partido Laborista que
ahora está en el gobierno, aunque no ponían
una fecha concreta, era partidario de negociarla.
Es decir que tampoco es que hubiera muchos
incentivos para invertir en la industria petrolera
y gasista del país.
Dicho de otra forma: es imposible dar la vuelta
en unos meses a años de desinversión.
Además algo que ha dificultado la compra
de gas en Europa es la capacidad europea de
regasificación.
Una forma rápida de abastecer el suministro
de gas es comprar gas natural licuado.
No habría que esperar a construir nuevos
gasoductos con Noruega ni otros países.
Pero la capacidad de regasificación de la
UE no es suficiente.
Alemania, que es el país que más gas consume
de la Unión Europea, no tenía ni una sola
planta de regasificación antes de la guerra
de Ucrania.
Y por supuesto, Noruega tampoco tiene la suficiente
capacidad de licuefacción.
Porque el GNL primero hay que licuefactar
y luego regasificarlo.
Necesitas capacidad en los dos extremos de
la cadena del transporte.
Dicho de otra forma: Europa necesita mucho
más gas del que Noruega puede ofrecer en
el corto plazo.
En otros videos de VisualPolitik os explicamos
más en detalle qué es el gas natural licuado
y cuales son las diferentes alternativas que
Europa está consiguiendo para intentar contrarrestar
la crisis energética.
Europa está diversificando en la compra de
gas y preparándose para recibir gas natural
licuado de diferentes países.
Pero ahora la gran pregunta es: ¿En Noruega
están siendo solidarios o hay algún interés
detrás?
¿Hay algún oscuro plan globalista detrás
de todo esto?
T3 (EL MONOPOLY DE NORUEGA)
Como os hemos dicho al principio del vídeo,
Noruega está ganando mucho dinero con el
tema de la guerra en Ucrania.
Vamos que se están haciendo de oro sin tener
que ir a saquear como el vikingo Olav.
¿Qué significa esto para el fondo soberano
de Noruega y la economía mundial?
Pues ojo porque solo en 2023 el gobierno noruego
espera ingresar gracias a la explotación
del crudo y el gas natural, más de 130 millones
de dólares.
Y eso no es todo.
De momento los ingresos de 2022 se estiman
en casi 120 mil millones de dólares.
¿Y sabéis cuanto ingresaron en 2021?
Pues algo menos de 30 mil millones.
Es decir, gracias a la guerra de Ucrania Noruega
va a ingresar en 2022 y 2023 el equivalente
a 8 años corrientes.
¿Y sabéis qué?
Gran parte de estos ingresos serán destinados
para su fondo soberano ¡Y esto no es ninguna
broma!
Noruega es ya la dueña del 1.3% de todas
las acciones que hay en el mundo.
Empresas como Nestlé, Apple o Microsoft tienen
al Fondo Soberano Noruego como uno de sus
mayores accionistas.
¡Y atentos porque aquí llega lo realmente
interesante!
Una ventaja de ser accionista de una empresa,
es que si tienes las suficientes acciones,
puedes llegar a influir en su rumbo.
Pues bien, hasta hace unos años este Fondo
Soberano no perseguía ninguna influencia
en las empresas en que invertía.
Digamos que se limitaba a excluir cierto tipo
de empresas de su cartera: básicamente fabricantes
de armas, productores de hidrocarburos, tabaco,
carbón o empresas con dudosos vínculos con
los derechos humanos…
Algo que por supuesto aún sigue haciendo.
(Por ejemplo, recientemente, el fondo puso
a la canadiense Bombardier y a la surcoreana
Hyundai Glovis en una lista de vigilancia
para la posible venta de su inversión.
En el caso de Hyundai, fue debido al supuesto
uso de desguaces en Pakistán y Bangladesh,
donde las condiciones laborales rozan la violación
de derechos humanos: al menos, según el fondo.
En el caso de Bombardier, la razón fueron
algunas sospechas de corrupción en diferentes
países.
Luego este mismo fondo también ha tenido
polémicas con el gobierno chino.
Por ejemplo, se deshicieron de todas las acciones
en la empresa deportiva Li-Ning, debido a
una aparente violación de los derechos humanos
en la región de Xinjiang.)
Sin embargo, desde algún tiempo la estrategia
del fondo ha comenzado a cambiar.
C3 ("Hemos evolucionado de ser un propietario
reacio a un propietario más activo [...] Al
principio, la idea era simplemente comprar
una porción de los mercados financieros globales
y nuestra intención no era ejercer ninguna
influencia sobre las empresas".
Trond Grande, Subdirector Ejecutivo del Fondo
Soberano de Noruega)
Por ejemplo, ya no resulta extraño para generar
presión que este fondo publique por adelantado
qué va a votar sobre determinados temas en
las juntas de accionistas.
Supuestamente lo hacen para mejorar el gobierno
de las empresas.
C4 (“Nuestro objetivo es fortalecer a las
empresas mediante una mejor gobernanza y mejorar
su gestión de los riesgos a largo plazo"
Trond Grande, Subdirector Ejecutivo del Fondo
Soberano de Noruega)
En esta línea en 2021 el fondo noruego votó
en 6 resoluciones en la Junta de Accionistas
de Facebook para que esta empresa fuera más
transparente y presentara informes mejorados.
Sin embargo, justo aquí está la cuestión
potencialmente más inquietante: que de cuestiones
meramente corporativas el Fondo Noruego pase
a presionar a las empresas con cuestiones
más culturales, identitarias o políticas.
Es decir, que trate de importar los valores
noruegos a las empresas en las que invierte.
Por ejemplo, en 2022, el fondo noruego votó
a favor de realizar un informe de derechos
humanos y realizar un informe sobre la brecha
salarial en la junta de accionistas de Disney.
Y algo parecido ocurrió en Amazon.
Noruega estuvo del lado de los trabajadores
de Amazon que querían montar un sindicato.
De hecho, en una junta de accionistas, Noruega
votó a favor del derecho de negociación
colectiva en contra de los intereses del propio
Jeff Bezos.
Como curiosidad, os diré que, en este caso,
Noruega perdió la votación.
Y lo hizo, entre otras cosas, porque las participaciones
del Fondo en las empresas suelen ser relativamente
pequeñas.
Pero claro, cuándo tienes tanto dinero lo
que dices dentro de una empresa cuanto menos
se escucha.
Y además puedes llegar a marcar tendencia.
Muchos otros fondos y accionistas pueden decidir
copiarte.
Para entendernos, podemos decir que Noruega
en la bolsa es como la chica popular en el
colegio que marca tendencias.
Y no solo eso, llegado el caso este fondo
podría comprar participaciones más grandes
en determinadas empresas para así poder influir
mucho más en ellas.
Podéis creerme, con más de 1 billón de
dólares en tu cartera de inversión puedes
hacer prácticamente lo que quieras.
¿Otro ejemplo?
Pues veréis, Noruega no solo es uno de los
países más ricos del mundo: también es
uno de los más igualitarios.
Y es precisamente este modelo social el que
intentan llevar a sus empresas.
De hecho ¿Sabéis cuál es una de las grandes
causas por las que lucha Noruega?
¡Exacto!
El sueldo de los directivos: Noruega lleva
años presionando a las empresas para que
bajen los sueldazos que pagan a sus directivos.
Esto significa una cosa:el fondo soberano
noruego puede terminar convirtiéndose en
una pesadilla para los CEOs.
Por eso no sorprendes titulares como este:
(" El mayor fondo soberano del mundo votará
contra el paquete salarial del CEO de Apple,
Tim Cook)
Y, ojo, el problema es que puedes empezar
con el salario de los directivos y terminar
con muchas otras iniciativas.
Digamos que llegado el caso Noruega puede
usar el fondo como arma política…
En una dirección o en otra.
Sin ir más lejos este año el Fondo anunció
que liquidará todos sus activos rusos.
Hablamos de unos 2.800 millones de dólares.
No es una gran suma si lo comparamos con las
inversiones que tienen en otros países…
Pero ahí queda.
Y, lógicamente, cuánto más dinero tenga
el Fondo, mayor será su influencia.
Así que si algo está claro es que el enorme
torrente de dinero que ahora está entrando
a raudales en el país de los fiordos si algo
va hacer es, precisamente, incrementar mucho
esta influencia.
¡Ojo!
Hay quienes han criticado duramente toda esta
forma de comportarse del fondo soberano noruego.
¿Por qué?
Pues porque perseguir intereses políticos
o ideológicos a la hora de invertir puede
resultar en pérdidas de rentabilidad.
Y esto pueden ser malas noticias para los
propios noruegos.
Claro que puestos a hablar de críticas…
Noruega también ha recibido fuertes críticas
por los grandes ingresos que están obteniendo
gracias a la guerra.
El propio primer ministro de Polonia, ha señalado
que Noruega se está beneficiando directamente
de la guerra y los ha instado a compartir
esta nueva riqueza con Ucrania.
Pero..
Sea como sea, ahora la pregunta es para vosotros:
¿Ayudaran más a Ucrania o buscarán invertir
más en su fondo soberano?
¿Conseguirá Noruega producir más gas para
salvar a Europa de la crisis energética?
¿Cuáles serán los próximos movimientos
del fondo soberano noruego?
Podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los comentarios.
Como siempre no olvidéis que aquí en VisualPolitik
sacamos vídeos nuevos todas las semanas así
que suscribiros a este canal y dadle a la
campanita para no perderos ninguna de nuestras
actualizaciones.
Si os ha gustado este vídeo, dadle a LIKE
y nos vemos en el próximo.
Un abrazo y hasta pronto.